hello everyone and welcome to the
long-awaited round 10 of the 2022 tata
still chess masters it's former world
chess championship challenger sergey
karjakin versus magnus carlsen uh
current world champion and a lot of
people were really waiting for this game
but it ended a bit anti-climactic
uh now why this is so uh let's check it
out and then i'm very very much
interested in your opinion on this as
there are a lot of different opinions on
this so let's uh let's check it out
karakan with the white pieces opens with
e5 uh we have e5 by map sorry with e4 e5
by magnus knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 and the the game actually
lasted i think not even 20 minutes so
most of the other games are still in the
opening phase uh so i decided to show
you guys this one and get your input on
it before we uh wait wait for the other
games to finish uh so bishop b5 the
royal opus is on the board we have
knight to f6 magnus goes for the berlin
defense we have castles now offering the
the real gambit and the knight captures
an e4 the real gambit is accepted rook
to e1 and knight to d6 so this is all
very standard stuff it's been played
many many times by pretty much everyone
knight captures on e5 and now bishop to
e7 preparing the castle you do not want
your king on the open file while the
rook is on e1 bishop back to f1 as it's
attacked on b5 this is again all very
very standard stuff and not knight to f5
by magnus uh the two of them already had
this position on the board in the tall
memorial in the 2013 uh where magnus
played knight captures on e5 that game
ended in a draw but here magnus plays
knight to f5 so he switches up from that
line and now c3 preparing to grab the
center with the d4
magnus trades on e5 we have rook
captures on e5 and now d6 and now you
you're chasing away the rook and also
the knight is now very well protected
and very nicely placed on on f5
rogue back to e1 and now we have castles
so d4 here
grabbing the center and now black will
waste one tempo to play d5 so you have
both of your bishops are very nicely
opened up and you have very nice control
over the e4 square with bishop to f4 and
now bishop to d6 offering a trade of
bishops here queen to f3 by karjakin and
now comes
knight to h4 by magnus uh interestingly
you could try some other moves here but
um
this is the main move in the position
and uh well uh it has been played quite
quite a lot and it's basically a draw
offer so after knight to h4 white really
doesn't have a good continuation here
because you either go to g3 or on e3 and
then black just repeats knight to f5
where and then white can choose to maybe
play something else and not have such an
active square for the queen or he can
play g3 as was played in the game but
now knight to f5 by magnus queen back to
f3 knight to h for queen g3 and knight
to f5 and he was in this position on
move 16 that magnus and sergey agreed to
a draw as obviously there is nothing
more to be done here
any other retreat
by the queen other than the one that was
in the game that will be insufficient
because if you try something like queen
g5 you offer a queen trade f6 and black
is pretty much winning now there's no
good square for the queen you have to go
to g4 and then you are under the mask of
the bishop for example knight captures
on d4 you already
lost the pawn and it's a much better
position now for black so after knight
to f5 they agreed to a draw and
interestingly it seems that sergey was
very happy about this right after the
game he tweeted this uh hashtag draw
magnus hashtag say no to 2900
so i'm very very much interested in what
you guys make of this is this um is this
uh
did magnus actually want a draw with the
black pieces against karjakin here uh as
he did play the berlin or maybe did he
try to mix it up uh from the line that
the two of them have already played or
or was it aimed at uh gaining such a
repetition was magnus maybe uh
not trying to go uh for a win with the
black pieces against uh karjakin uh it's
it's hard to say because the two of them
have played the world chess championship
match together in 2016
uh in new york and uh karjakin was one
of the one of the strongest opponents uh
magnus faced as uh he he
uh took a lead in the tournament and
then magnus was able to bounce back to
two games after uh he lost but yeah very
much interesting what do you guys think
like i said uh all of the games are
still pretty much in the opening phase
so i decided to uh to get this one out
to get your input uh so yeah that's the
game i know you didn't enjoy it but uh
you know it it did happen and it's a
pretty important one for the standings i
would like to thank david kimura thomas
earl trevor for todo souza uh guing guo
khan and william rose for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh as soon as the the next um a
nice game uh finishes uh so yeah thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day